.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THAT.
I WANT TO BRING IN OUR CNN
SENIOR JUSTICE CORRESPONDENT,
EVAN PEREZ.
EVAN, YOU SAID SOMETHING
INTERESTING THAT I EVEN CALLED
YOU ABOUT, BECAUSE I SAID, WHAT?
THIS IS REALLY CRITICAL.
AND IT'S ABOUT THE THREE LAWS
THAT ARE CITED IN THIS SEARCH
WARRANT.
YOU HEAR THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
OR SEE HIM IN HIS STATEMENTS
TODAY SAYING, I DIDN'T TAKE ANY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
BUT YOU ARE REPORTING THAT THAT
IS NOT NECESSARILY RELEVANT.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THAT?
>> WELL, YEAH.
SO THE THREE LAWS, I WILL READ
YOU THE THREE FEDERAL CODES.
ONE IS SEVEN 93, THAT'S KNOWN
AS THE ESPIONAGE ACT.
GATHERING, TRANSMITTING, OR
LOSING DEFENSE INFORMATION.
COTA 15 19, THIS IS DESTRUCTION,
ALTERATION, FALSIFICATION OF
RECORDS IN FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION.
THIS IS AN OBSTRUCTION STATUTE.
AND THEN 2071, WHICH IS
CONCEALMENT AND MUTILATION OF
FEDERAL DOCUMENTS.
WHAT'S INTERESTING --
ESPECIALLY IF YOU LOOK AT SEVEN
93, WHICH IS THE ESPIONAGE ACT,
THE NATIONAL DEFENSE
INFORMATION, IT DOESN'T REALLY
TURN ON WHETHER THE ITEMS WERE
DECLASSIFIED, IT DOESN'T TURN
ON WHETHER YOU HAVE OFF THE
WORRY TO POSSESS THESE
DOCUMENTS.
SO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT,
ACCORDING TO THIS DOCUMENT, THE
PROSECUTORS AND THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT ARE INVESTIGATING
POSSIBLE CRIMES.
THIS IS THE PROOF THEY GAVE TO
A FEDERAL JUDGE TO SAY WE
BELIEVE AT MAR-A-LAGO, THERE
WERE EVIDENCE OF THESE CRIMES.
WHAT IS IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS IS
THAT THEY ARE USING SPECIFIC
LAWS THAT COULD INOCULATE THEIR
INVESTIGATION FROM WHAT WE
EXPECT TO BE THE SUREFIRE
DONALD TRUMP'S DEFENSE.
WHICH IS, I DECLASSIFIED
EVERYTHING.
BY SAYING SO, I AUTOMATICALLY
DECLASSIFIED THINGS.
OF COURSE, WE KNOW IT'S A
LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED THAN
THAT.
BUT THAT'S WHERE WE KNOW DONALD
TRUMP IS GOING TO GO.
WE CAN ALREADY SEE THAT IN SOME
OF HIS DEFENSES.
ONE OTHER THING THAT STOOD OUT
TO ME FROM THIS DOCUMENT,
REALLY QUICK, IS THAT THE
DOCUMENT SAYS THAT THE JUDGES
AUTHORIZING THE JUDGE TO SHOW
UP FROM 6 AM TO 10 PM.
WE KNOW THAT THE FBI SHOWED UP
AROUND 10 AM.
IT GIVES YOU A SENSE OF THE
DEFERENCE THEY WERE GIVING TO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT AND THE
OFFICE THAT HE HELD.
THEY COULD HAVE GONE IN THERE
WITH THEIR FBI JACKETS.
THEY CAME IN WITH SUITS AND
TIES, THEY CAME AROUND 10 AM.
THEY WERE TRYING TO NOT MAKE
THIS A SPECTACLE.
HE IS THE ONE THAT WENT OUT
RIGHT AFTER THE FBI LEFT THE
PRIMACY'S, AND BLASTED OUT HIS
STATEMENT AND CREATED A
SPECTACLE OF WHAT HAD HAPPENED
HERE.
>> EVAN, THAT IS VERY
INTERESTING AND AN IMPORTANT
POINT.
BECAUSE NOW WE DO HAVE THESE
TIME STAMPS.
BUT BACK TO YOUR ORIGINAL
POINT.
IF THE FORMER PRESIDENT DIDN'T
NECESSARILY BREAK THE LAW, JUST
USE LAYMAN'S TERMS, BECAUSE --
OR THIS WASN'T PRECIPITATED
BECAUSE OF HIS POSSESSION OF
ANY CLASSIFIED INFORMATION,
WHAT WOULD BE THE POTENTIAL
AREA WHERE HE DID BREAK THE LAW?
>> WELL, WHAT THIS MEANS IS
THAT IT DOESN'T MATTER THAT IT
WAS CLASSIFIED OR NOT.
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO SAY, BY
PRESENTING THESE STATUTES AS
THE REASON FOR DOING THE SEARCH,
WITH THE PROSECUTORS ARE DOING
HIS SIGNATURE THIS WAS A
VIOLATION OF THE LAW BECAUSE
SIMPLY BY PUTTING THESE
DOCUMENTS, WHICH COULD HARM THE
UNITED STATES, THIS NATIONAL
DEFENCE INFORMATION DOCUMENTS,
THAT YOU ARE VIOLATING THE LAW.
YOU WOULD VIOLATE THE LAW EVEN
IF YOU, AS FORMER PRESIDENT,
DECLASSIFIED THEM.
WHICH IS, I THINK, WHAT HE IS
GOING TO ARGUE.
SO WHAT THIS MEANS IS THAT YOU